avant toute chose je rappelle que cette
chaîne n'est pas fait à la base pour
réviser le bac c'est juste une chaîne
faite pour parler ensemble de philo de
manière fun
voilà mes bons defacto il ya pas mal de
gens qui utilisent pour ça donc je fais
cette vidéo you say cyrus c'est bientôt
le bac de philo et ces derniers jours
c'est un petit peu fou tout ce qui se
passe sur la chaîne genre vous êtes
beaucoup beaucoup à venir je reçois
plein de commentaires pleins
remerciements et ça passe ça fait
vachement vachement plaisir et du coup
je me suis dit est-ce qu'il ya pas un
moyen que je vous rends un petit peu le
truc
sachant que j'ai déjà fait une vidéo sur
le bike l'année dernière qui est
toujours valable c'est une vidéo sur les
conseils généraux autour du bac de philo
donc voilà le savez dans la déception
est bref je me suis dis pas ça sympa tu
as un petit truc juste un petit truc
parce que là il est
vendredi soir il est actuellement une
heure du matin et donc chercher un truc
rapide offert j'ai pensé à un abécédaire
en plus à un permettre de mettre un peu
plus de clarté dans la chaîne et c'est à
dire bat sur chaque concept où chaque
mot ou dire bah là c'est intéressant
d'aller voir cette vidéo pour ce concept
là où cette explication là etc
voilà c'est parti à comme absolue
quelque chose d'absolu c'est quelque
chose qui va être portée à son degré
maximal
c'est à dire sans aucune limite par
exemple l'amour absolu où la liberté
absolue c'est quelque chose qui s'oppose
donc à relatifs
ça peut aussi être quelque chose qui
s'auto suffit b comme le bonheur le
bonheur c'est vraiment un truc on
recherche tous genres tous les hommes
recherchent le bonheur et du coup t'as
pas mal de philosophes qui ont essayé
d'y apporter des solutions sur des
moyens pour y arriver et c'est et les
deux grosses et stoïcisme épicurisme on
a vu ensemble
j'ai fait un tableau comparatif que je
mets dans la description et j'ai même
fait une vidéo sur le stoïcisme une
vidéo sur l'épicurisme pareil tout est à
l'inscription
tout sera toute façon tout le temps la
description hockey
le parterre d'annotations sinon ce
serait trop lourd c'est comme conscience
la conscience et la connaissance qu'a
l'homme de ses sentiments de ses pensées
de ses actes et en gros la conscience on
peut la qualifier ça peut être la bonne
conscience la mauvaise conscience et
souvent à va de pair avec le prg est
conscient et l'inconscient
l'inconscience un truc dont j'ai parlé
dans le coup de fil numéro cinq sur fred
et jamy des comme déterminisme le
déterminisme c'est le principe qui dit
que tous les phénomènes sont liés par
des relations de causalité c'est à dire
des relations de cause à effet et donc
c'est à dire qu'il ya pas de hasard donc
si voulez en savoir plus sur le
déterminisme ça a été vachement
développé par spinoza et c'est dans la
vidéo du coup de fil numéro 10 peu comme
empirisme empirisme c'est une
philosophie qui dit que toutes nos
connaissances à nous viennent de
l'expérience alors quand je parle
d'expérience par pas d'expérience
chimiques ou quoi te parle de
l'expérience bas les choses que tu
expérimente au jour le jour quoi donc
s'il n'y avait pas d'expérience on
aurait pas eu connaissance ça a été
vachement développé par john locke et il
ya un coup de fil de sucer le coup de
fil numéro 14
f comme en fait et en droit alors dans
une copie de philo tu peux pas dire en
fait comme tu me dire est dans la vraie
vie
ouais ben en fait c'était pas mal non en
fait dans une copie de philo c'est dans
les faits c'est à dire chose qui existe
en droit c'est plus ce genre ce que tu
en droit te demander genre si c'est
légitime si c'est justifié si c'est
légal ou des choses comme ça ça existe
en fait
mais est-ce que c'est fondé en droit
j'ai comme genèse c'est le développement
la formation de quelque chose et c'est
aussi le premier livre de la bible h
comme hédonisme l'hédonisme c'est une
doctrine qui fait du plaisir le principe
ou le but de la vie alors attention
parce que dans le sens courant ça veut
dire un petit peu la course au plaisir
de manière in modéré et c'est pas ce que
dit le sens littéral icom intrinsèque ci
a et un point c'est k b c'est à dire que
a est inclus dans la nature ou la
définition de b/j comme justice alors a
peut être commis natives comme dans le
commerce par exemple séquence qui est dû
à chacun peut être interchangeable c'est
à dire que tu dois rendre autant que tu
reçois où elle peut être distributive
c'est ce qu'ont adjugé à chacun en
fonction du mérite
en gros
tribu les pn et les récompenses cas
comme quand alors je teins métal est
sûre quand ici dans cette vidéo
jean dit déjà beaucoup dans le country
numéro 15 l comme libre arbitre alors
c'est vachement important c'est la
capacité à être la première cause de vos
actes c'est vachement lié aussi à
l'existentialisme de sartre donc je vous
invite à aller voir le coup de fil
numéro 4 qui vous donnera une meilleure
idée de ce que c'est le libre arbitre m
comme morale alors la morale c'est les
objectifs qu'on se donne les moyens d'y
parvenir
donc du coup il ya différentes moral
souvent chaque philosophie par contre si
elle allait à la morale stoïcienne ya la
morale épicurienne il ya la morale qu
ancien mais je pense qu'on peut pas
parler de morale en tout cas on peut
parler de morale mais c'est vachement
cool d'aller voir la morale de machiavel
parce que il se met un petit peu à
contre-pied par rapport à tout ça parce
qu'elle a une vision vachement
intéressante c'est le coup de fil numéro
2 n comme nécessaire nécessaire ce qui
ne peut pas ne pas être forcément là et
ça s'opposa contingent ce qui peut ne
pas être au comme objectif alors quelque
chose d'objectif c'est quelque chose qui
existe en dehors de ton esprit ou alors
ça existe dans ton esprit mais sans
interprétation et l' inverse du coup
c'est subjectif
p comme paradigme paradigme c'est une
vision du monde en fait genre par
exemple avant penser que la terre était
plate
on a appris que la terre était ronde ok
nouveau paradigme on pensait que tout
tournait autour de la terre en fait on
s'est rendu compte que la terre tournait
autour du soleil très bien nouveau
paradigme une vision du monde
q alors que c'est la partie du corps
préféré de toutes les offres qui se
respecte r comme réalité et raison est
ce que ma raison peut m'aider à voir si
le monde qui m'entoure est vraiment réel
parce que c'est la question que se
posent des cartes et laisser dire et
ponts avec le cockpit au et j'en parle
dans le coup de fil numéro 6 aces comme
sensibles alors attention quelque chose
qui est sensible c'est pas quelque chose
qui va pleurer pour rien c'est juste
quelque chose qui va être perçue par les
sens t comme transcendant si à être
ensemble en avait alors à des passes
surpasse b à et au delà de b uf comme
utilitarisme alors l'utilitarisme c'est
une doctrine morale pour laquelle une
action bonne
c'est une action qui a pour but le plus
grand bonheur aux plus grandes
v comme volonté de puissance alors
volonté de puissance un concept
vachement important chez nietzsche
si vous voyez pas ce que c'est je vous
envoie vers le coup de fil 17 sur le
surhomme
w comme double vente et de puissance
alors c'est comme la vente et de
puissance mais c'est deux fois plus
puissant it's comme le y c'est le iota
c'est la neuvième lettres de l'alphabet
grec c'est le y z c'est pas évident de
finir cet alphabet un désespère que ça
vous a plu voilà c'est une petite vidéo
qui va être là juste pour ce bac de 2015
et elle va sûrement être mise à jour en
2016 avec les nouvelles vidéos que
j'aurais sorti et c'est pour mieux
agencé tout ça ou alors il sera
supprimée avant j'en sais rien en fait
voilà je balance un petit peu comme ça
j'espère que ça va vous aider et surtout
ça se substitue à rien ça ne suffit pas
c'est juste des petits goodies mais ça
ne remplace pas les vrais révision je ne
suis rendu compte que j'ai oublié de
vous dire deux choses un bon chance et
de continuer à vous intéresser à la
philo même après le bac
que ce soit bien ma chaîne où il ya
autre chose surtout continuer ok si ça
vous a plu
le matin quand vous allez à l'épreuve
l'oeil du tigre l'a eue du tigre mec